non mes excuses moi ce reçu la 2 carte
bleue pour deux jours à l'hôtel costes
mais c'est que je crois quoi moi un coup
irait pas dans mes potes aurait pas ce
genre de surprise messieurs c'est quand
même incroyable mauvaise oil mauvaise
foi oui tu dois je n'étais pas le seul à
le déloger débat tout seul oui j'ai sept
villages de foule tout seul dans un
hôtel de toute façon et si tu voyais pas
tu trouverais pas mais la dtt tu
fouilles du bénin
hu à mes yeux où il regarde on à bouche
à bouche cascades de 10 fois quel temps
meilleurs bon attention bertrand
je porterai pas plus longtemps des
insultes comme ça ok voilà non c'est pas
voilà c'est à peu près le genre de coupe
que vous êtes on a fait une étude on a
bien regardé c'est ce profil là je pense
qu'on peut vous aider
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous faites là
mais côté nuit
ok d'accord un petit coup vite fait je
fais pas mal angers on va faire ça
directe contre le mur
[Musique]